[Music]
[Music]
very pleased to introduce professor
Kahneman from the ad ha in Suresh and
University of Florida in Gainesville he
of course needs no introduction amongst
his many honors includes the Kyoto prize
I think you're one of the first winners
of the Kyoto Prize the first winner I
stand corrected of the Kyoto Prize which
in the eyes of many are equivalent or
perhaps higher than the Nobel prizes
he's going to talk to us today about
randomness as a systems phenomenon
I have a habit which is perhaps
unfortunate of being most eager to
lecture on problems which are not solved
in the hope that my efforts and the
lecture will be rewarded by some
interesting comments or interaction
later which sometimes happens today I'm
going to talk about a problem that in
some sense is solved but at the same
time this solution gives rise to a new
problem so I'm doing both talking about
a salt problem about an unsolved problem
well first of all let me say a word
about the word stochastic usually in the
literature of stochastics and randomness
are treated as roughly the same thing
and the trouble with our current
misunderstandings about a lot of things
begins already with this word in the
article in the encyclopedia britannica
dealing with linus pauling
a very successful and very earnest
scientist his approach to science is
characterized as a stochastic method
which is explained because this is a
Greek word it's explained in the article
as meaning aims to divine the truth by
conjecture
very roughly speaking and I think it's
fair to say that all this stuff one can
abbreviate it with the English word yes
and was the method is you guess
of course linus pauling guessing or my
you guessing are quite different things
so I don't want to make fun of that but
nevertheless that is the that is the
meaning now I have some Greek
connections and therefore I wanted to
find out whether this interpretation
meets with their approval and here is a
and generally they say it's not true but
I have a I have a letter from somebody
who was certified to be Greek and says
visualize our conclusions by guessing so
that seems to be the origin of the word
stochastics now for a very long time
people have voiced various kinds of
reservations about the way probabilistic
modeling or probabilistic reasoning is
used in regard to explaining phenomenon
in the real world
for example guy named Einstein said and
this is terribly well known although
never recorded by Einstein himself he
said God does not play dice
some people would would interpret this
as as Einstein's denying that there is
randomness in nature but I think that's
a very crude way of interpreting a
statement there are lots of other ways
of looking at it
so let's just take it literally God does
not play dice and I'll come back to it
second Cannavaro was supposed to have
said that there is something wrong wrong
with statistics unfortunately I don't
have a written reference to the
statement but I did put it in one of my
own papers so I can reference my own
paper for this statement and of course
the question is what is wrong with
statistics and if you're interested in
the answer that question there's a paper
that will be written next week which
will provide certain answer that much of
it I will cover also myself and then
finally to come back to the more
classical side of the subject perhaps
the greatest expert on probability
theory was bruno de Finetti
yet written a big treatise on
probability theory and I give you here a
part of the preface which i think is
fairly explicit probability does not
exist in the real world I think my dad
now one more point that should be made
is that the issue that is discussed here
namely can I arrived at the truth by
guessing has a long history which is
associated prominently was the name of
Newton who said in 1713 that he put a is
s known thing go this is a kind of Latin
that cannot be translated completely
accurately in polite company
it's not the expression thing goes not
quite light but it has an obvious
meaning it says I do not dream up
hypotheses to explain the facts I let
the facts explain themselves so my main
point in this lecture will be to simply
say that the question of relationship
between stochastic models and the real
world is something that cannot be
handled by guessing this relationship
cannot be handled by guessing from a
general point of view but it was handled
that way in most of the time that people
have attempted to look at this question
in spite of authorities like Newton's
who would have been very unhappy if he
had really paid attention to what they
knew he was doing right around this time
but Brno II I remind you was mainly
interested in things like card games
that was the main application of
probability theory at that time my
objections do not apply to card games
because those are constituted in such a
fashion that the axioms of probability
are automatically satisfied by putting
yourself in a certain well-defined
idealized situation well I am interested
in the relationship between stochastics
in the real world and this relationship
has not been adequately explored aside
from statements like what you see there
I would furthermore add that this is a
researchable question it's not a
question that should be debated purely
on religious grounds which is how it is
normally debated today now
there has been quite a bit of discussion
about these questions in the past and
one of the slogans which brings out the
objections to the usual procedure is
called SSB use an abbreviation used by
delaio
which means standard statistical
prejudice some people are very unhappy
about the word prejudice which
incidentally is already used by Newton
in the same context see potatoes non
finger if you don't like this let just
replace it by the word in appropriate
assumptions so you could say that
Einstein didn't mean to say that it's a
prejudice that God plays dice he could
have meant it's an inappropriate
assumption in looking at the physical
world that God plays lies so there is a
standard statistical prejudice which is
what we take a so called population with
a fixed invariant probability
distribution we assume that this object
exists and then usually also add to it
the notional independent sampling and my
point is that none of these notions are
things that can be really tested or
researched in regard to the real world
these are all on the level of
assumptions there are very heavy use of
hypothesis thing error in the sense that
Newton does not like and the situation
is so bad that in my personal opinion
which I will very briefly sketchy only
here
it is not possible to proceed along
these lines further than has been done
already and you have to take a
drastically different point of view the
drastically different point of view
means that you will study mainly the
notion of randomness and much less
notional probability the randomness
probability will be cheated and induced
thing and it's quite difficult to
determine in the natural world you can
easily measure the cross sections of
nuclear reactions relatively easily but
nobody in the physical world today has
machines that really measure things like
probabilities in other words it's a kind
of notion it's not suitable in many ways
for a direct definition or direct study
so I want to introduce a new definition
of randomness and I will say almost
nothing about probability the definition
of randomness will be the following okay
whatever is not determined or if you
like constrained by classical rules by
which I mean of course macroscopic
mathematically precise things precise
rules so whatever you're in that
situation which could be such that
everything is uniquely determined if
things are not uniquely determined then
whatever is there has to be regarded as
random for lack of any better word but
this randomness I claim is describes
very quickly and directly a lot of the
obviously random phenomena that you see
in the real world in a way that
conventional probability never even came
close to describe it let me give a few
simple examples and then at the end our
report on investigation is directly
related to economics which is not only
successful but it forces me to make this
kind of a definition I could not use any
other definition on the basis of the
facts that I have available so an
example is suppose we expand the square
root of 2 into a decimal fraction which
continues a little longer than this to 1
3 5 6
now in a certain sense it's not all
random because the number two occurs
twice for occurs twice one occurs twice
and seven for example doesn't occur at
all and so forth nevertheless according
to my definition I would have to call
this random why because the only thing I
can say on the basis of classical
knowledge about such a sequence is that
it's ultimately periodic that would be a
classical knowledge periodic of course
is highly regular and it's certainly not
random oh if ever the case is a rational
number
but of course already the Greeks knew
but this was not a rational number and
therefore this is random so we take a
point of view that's quite compatible
with the Greeks namely that whatever is
not rational that is to say given in
this kind of a way is has to be done it
does render this leaves open a question
of trying to prove if you really
interested what is the distribution of
digits in this expansion and there's a
little bit of literature available for
that but to the best of my knowledge
nobody has ever in a mathematically
useful way been able to define a joint
probability distribution for all the
possible n tuples of digits in the
sequence that sort of activity is not
interesting from the present point of
view because it is not information that
is that is that is relevant to the basic
question but it seems to be perfectly
obvious that this should be a random C
sequence also in the sense of
approximately equal occurrence of these
digits and that seems to be an empirical
fact so that's that's how far we want to
go with such a definition now second
definition example which I will just
mention the name is academician Tucanos
who is credited with a famous theorem in
topology and it's now well over 80 years
old had published a number of papers
between 1980 and 1990 including a book I
think about 89 or 90 on
treatment of experimental data roughly
speaking he sets of certain examples
which I have published and talked about
in other places and attempts to analyze
these examples in such a fashion that he
runs into the problem of defining what
is random and not random and makes a
horrible mistake this is totally wrong I
can't explain exactly because that's a
lot of times exactly why this is totally
wrong but it will be related to the
discussion toward the end of lecture and
the difficulty is simply that he uses an
approach to the subject which tries to
dodge the notion of randomness in the
sense that I'm talking about it here
another example is leaves on a tree if
you look at any reasonable tree of a
given specific type then the
distribution of leaves on this tree has
it has a roughly random appearance but
of course not totally random there's a
certain regularity as well now from the
point of your conventional probability
theory it's completely crazy to imagine
that you would describe the joint
probability distribution of all these
leaves it's just doesn't make any sense
this would be a tremendous job when you
do it when you're finished with it it
will not be interesting and so forth but
there's a theory for this called the
Lindenmayer systems and the Lindenmayer
systems are an immediate explanation of
randomness in this sense namely these
are like finite automata but
with a not necessarily deterministic
transition function I was as the
subfamily evolves similar to the growth
of the tree
occasionally points occur were either of
two or more decisions as possible and it
is this non uniqueness of decisions that
leads to the observed randomness of each
of the trees this can be simulated by
computer graphic experiments and young
amazing agreement with the real world
without of course of going to deeper
into questions of this sort so the
essential point of my definition
randomness is that it looks as at the
world as possibly determined by
classical rules uniquely or possibly non
uniquely determined by these classical
rules that may very well happen that on
a microscopic level there's some
additional rules in operation so we
don't claim that such such things are
necessarily random in the sense of not
being deterministic but the essential
issue is that it's the fact that in the
real world not everything is determined
uniquely by by over all classical rules
why that is so is something I'm not
going to speculate about in accordance
with Newton's statement
let me give press one more example if
which illustrates how I want to use
these words suppose you take a cube and
throw it how do I apply this idea well a
cube cannot cover equilibrium on a
vertex or an edge by some sort of a
general notion of stability but it could
come to equilibrium on a face which are
exactly six so as far as macroscopic
rules of mechanics are concerned these
rules simply say that that the cube will
end up on one of the six faces when you
throw it and it says nothing about which
of the six faces it will come to rest on
then it's a reasonable argument that
because of symmetry the probability of
each of six faces should be the same but
that's a kind of discussion that is not
necessary here I don't want to go into
it and in in more complicated situation
and termination such probabilities for
for more direct physical prints all this
is a complicated matter but I'd like to
mention that apparently there's some
work going on in the following thing you
throw the die and at some point the pass
is deterministic because according to
classical physics everything is exactly
determined by the conditions here and
then at some point this becomes in
deterministic and the physicists seem to
be amused by the question where does
this thing become in deterministic I
think that's complete nonsense and to
avoid such complete nonsense
we have to use my definition of
randomness there's no such thing as
transition from deterministic in
deterministic and all that okay now I'd
like to talk about a specific example
that came up in them
econometrics what which has a general
significance and then I will show some
experimental results so there is a
connection with the real world the
example the main example is a fault
suppose I'm given a cloud of points
points XT in RN T small or large number
but T in any case will be thought of as
being bigger than n naught I say much
bigger and I asked the question do these
points satisfy a linear relation which
can be expressed in this form the matrix
a prime denoting a collection of rows
each row being one particular linear
relation and for various purposes it's
necessary to technically assume that the
rank of a prime is maximum which means
that it will be equal to Q when I take Q
linear relations so I consider a Q by n
matrix the question is is there such a
little linear relation in the data it's
a trivial exercise in pure mathematics
to prove that if that relation is
satisfied by the data like this in which
case I call the data exact a prime is
unique so a major fact in this situation
as a prime is unique you satisfy
Newton's victim nothing is assumed it's
the data once this is satisfied that
automatically gives you a prime unique
in a mathematically sophisticated sense
not in a stupid sense the numbers are
not necessarily unique but that's not
important now the issue is in the real
world you have necessarily a situation
that can be thought of as X hat plus X
tilde T namely the actual data is
is consisting of an exact part and the
noise part that's a totally conventional
assumption so called additive noise but
now at this point there is a serious
question a lot of proceed according to
the standard statistical prejudice X
tilde T will be defined as a random
vector with all that the assumption
implies in particular the normal
definition the customary definition is
something like this X 1 tilde T is
Gaussian 0 mean fixed variance and X
tilde K T 0 for all K not equal to 1
that's a typical example of the
application of standard statistical
prejudice that is to say I take into
account a serial object which is a
Gaussian random vector with certain
specific assumptions and then I analyze
a problem on this basis now the reason
why this standard statistical prejudice
is not acceptable is somewhat subtle it
could be acceptable in the case I guess
right it is possible in the real world
to imagine that the data has actually
been prepared in such a fashion that
this assumption is true for example you
can run a simulation experiment in which
you simply put this assumption into the
data so if it's true then the assumption
is harmless but the question is how can
I check whether it's true or not and
second what do I do when the assumption
is wrong so in practical terms
the trouble is simply this that few
people have the imagination and that's
almost theorem to be able to test all
such prejudices at the same time which
would eliminate the weaken the word
prejudice considerably as long as I make
one assumption I'm certainly in a
prejudice situation if I look at all
possible assumptions and in a less
prejudiced situation so in the example
to be discussed it turns out that I
could make an assumption provided I'm
very careful of not fixing the prejudice
at the beginning but toward the end of
the investigation but then it turns out
that the assumption will not by me very
much it it may be correct but it has no
serious explanatory power so a new
approach has to be found and the new
approach essentially says that to
produce noise so that a linear relation
will be exactly satisfied in the exact
part of the data I have to be very
careful about how I produce this
particular noise so I have to check
various possibilities it's not known
even in the simple case as to what the
most up to what an optimal or most
reliable procedure might be but there
are some practical suggestions so to get
to that point let me introduce the
definition that Sigma is the covariance
matrix of X and similarly Sigma hat and
Sigma tilde then I could look at the
following situation to avoid explicitly
making me the standard statistical
prejudice I could say that one Sigma hat
has a given co rank Q just due to the
fact that the equation ax hat equals 0
is equivalent to the equation
a hat a prime Sigma hat equals zero and
the core angle Sigma hat will turn out
to be the rank of the matrix a so this
assumption in regard to looking at
linear relations is precisely equivalent
to what I've written over there the
second assumption would be I look at the
situation in low-noise namely I assume
that Sigma tilde norm is less than say
epsilon if I do not make any assumption
about noise for example I could declare
in this situation the whole data to be
noise the exact part zero then of course
I don't get anywhere therefore it's so
interest to see whether or not some
other assumption you know is namely a
small amount of noise it has some
explanatory power for a given set of
data or not now this question was first
considered to the best of my knowledge
in the literature in a famous book by
Ragnar Frisch published in 1974 which
most people have not understood in fact
I guarantee that nobody had understood
it including Frisch apparently he hasn't
written it professor sampson told me a
couple days ago they was probably
written by freshers student hall well mo
who got the Nobel Prize in 1989 and I'm
quite sure that over quite sure from
direct contact that homo certainly
hasn't understood it so we have a
serious problem but it's not too
important for the present lecture so
Frisch wanted to check something related
to this situation here and he produced
some simulated data which unfortunately
is not published in the book but only
the corresponding covariance matrix
Sigma but we know that the simulated
data had low noise namely approximately
10% in terms of X tilde so X still it
was about 10%
of X X tilde equals 10% of X which is
relatively Illinois's he then attempted
to have a numerical procedure for
getting back the assumptions he put in
the data for example determining q and
him
verifying that the laws would always was
lower for reasons that I am unable to
fully understand
Frisch did not succeed fully in this
experiment although he sort of tried it
and therefore the experiment has to be
redone
now show you the main results on them I
should add one more thing appreciate a
method of of investigating is problem
that's the following plot call the
zeroes of Sigma minus 1 this
prescription can be to some extent
justified as follows each row each row
of Sigma minus 1 written as a prime I
satisfies the relation here for suitable
definition of X still there
and these things are known as the
elementary regressions in so called
least square sense which is too
technical to explain here but it means
what you think it does
meaning that X tilde I T is not
identically 0 so an elementary
regression is a way of looking at the
data in the light of the standard
statistical prejudice which makes an
assumption like this except that you
vary the variable that's allowed to be
noisy all other variables are always not
noisy that's the meaning of plotting the
rows of Sigma minus 1
and plot the normalized rows namely one
variable one coefficient will be one so
that the a prime I will be written in
the format one alpha beta or something
like that in in the situation that fish
was concerned with we had N equals 4 and
Q equals 2 these assumptions plus the
low noise are put into the data now if
you analyze this by a modern procedure
which I cannot at this point explain in
detail you obtain a following plot this
is real computation obtained only about
a couple of weeks ago as a check to make
sure everything make some mistake and
then using a fish data now what's
interesting in this plot is that all
four points are on the same straight
line these are the four roles of Sigma
minus one if you have four points in the
straight line it surely has some major
mathematical significance
so to understand fish did not plot this
thing which was a terrible mistake and
in fact he did not really understand the
whole thing but he was very close to
understanding it so from the practical
point of view what you have to do is as
suppose I see this never mind why I'll
explain that later what is the
explanation that all points lie in a
straight line
well the explanation is straightforward
we have a theorem theorem says that
under these circumstances when n is
equal to 2 all points will lie on a line
with a certain band around it the
thickness of a band being epsilon plus
minus Epsilon
the points will lie within here and so
forth if and only if the assumptions I
stated there are met there was if and
only if we have this situation with Q
equal to 2
then if you perform a plot of the rows
of Sigma minus one they must lie in a
straight line and you can measure the
amount of noise by measuring the epsilon
amount of noise relative to the rows of
Sigma minus one by measuring how far
these points are from the state line now
in the plot that you see there's no
cheating if you look at it very
carefully these things are not exactly
on the line but they're so close that
within the normal accuracy of such a
display you can't tell any difference
but they're not exactly on the line by
measuring how far away from the line you
are you get an estimate for the epsilon
so this is the solution of the
simulation problem Frisch namely if I do
what fish says then I get a an
indication indication of the situation
in this data which is strongly
characterized by the number Q and also
by this epsilon if epsilon is large
forget about it if your data is very
noisy it's not worth taking sword away
statisticians have traditionally made a
terrible mistake in trying to explore
the unknown by concentrating on the
noise scientists on the other hand
regard noise with a certain amount of
contempt and their interest is getting
things like the straight line the
straight line is really a system that's
in in the date on which you have
identified and you see there's no
fuzziness whatever about the straight
line at least within the accuracy of the
picture so this is a situation
concerning fishes Bach witches which is
now available however historically this
was not how it how things went
historically I became interested for
various reasons in data published in the
book of Milan involve a French
econometrics textbook which used data
from the French economy as shown in
these diagrams and
which you can see perhaps a little
better when it's plotted against time
that's here so in terms of time behavior
you see that the these three variables
are roughly moving together and the last
variable is small and essentially random
now under these circumstances
you would ask what can be say for sure
about the apparently random behavior of
these three variables forgetting the
third variable which is obviously noise
I come back later to the question what
to do when one variable is suspected to
be noise how to verify that fact now one
of the techniques that is one thing you
could do is take the whole data from
1949 to 1966 or compute the covariance
matrices for that and by some theory try
to decide what Q is so we have the fact
that from 1949 to 1966 by various ad-hoc
methods you can verify the Q's equal to
two and everything would be simple but
this is not a completely satisfactory
statement because obviously this data
may have a time varying component in it
and it is desirable to investigate
whether the behavior of a system in a
French economy significantly different
for example over this period of time or
over this period of time in his book
Mullen wall claims that the common
market brought about a big change from
6266 and one might be interested in
checking whether claim is right or not
now furthermore even in the standard
statistical prejudice it is a fact that
if you subdivide the data the
subsets of the data must satisfy exactly
the same assumptions as the whole data
so for example if I assume this for all
T then four subsets of tedius must also
hold that's a simple mathematical
feature of all such things therefore
will be interesting to see what happens
if you look at the data in a segmented
way and now we will see what happens if
you have five year windows in the data
this situation was first investigated on
July 20 1983 and I got the results back
around approximately 11:58 a.m. a point
in time which which rather accurately
marks the death of classical
econometrics now the question is exactly
why it is so and I have to make one more
explanation before showing you the
slides the theory as it existed in 1986
was not yet freed 83 was not yet freed
from the prejudice I've discussed is
also so-called fresh prejudice the fresh
prejudice says that Sigma tilde is a
diagonal matrix it can be shown that
under certain circumstances you can
arrange the noise so that the data
covariance of the noise this is these
are all data covariance is not
population if no population discussed at
all but the data covariance of Lewis is
diagonal then when n is equal to 3 there
are two situations either the three
points that we're plotting or some are
together like this thank you is equal to
one or they are like this three
different quadrants and then Q is equal
to two
so we want to know whether the statement
that the data contains q1 or q2 which is
the critical question of the nature of
the data is verified by looking at the
windows ok so let me begin showing you
the various windows were plotting 3
rolls over 3x3 covariance matrix on the
first window for 1949 through 54 I think
looks like that that's rather
interesting you see a straight line
between the three points actually what
you draw by the computer is a triangle
connecting the three points but the
result is a straight line of course now
we know that this has something to do
with the free simulation experiment but
at the time that this was done that
conclusion was not yet clear we take a
second window we have similar situation
but the points are quite different for
the third window the points happen to
coincide notice that they're always in
the second quadrant for the next window
the points now correspond to Q equals 2
in the fish sense so far they were
cubicles one in the fish sense and
they're all over for next window the
points again coincide
for the next window they coincide about
where they are but now they're in the
other quadrant in the fourth quadrant
once more they occur inside like that
and then something happens the thing
explodes and there's a point off this
particular scale but again they're in
the third quadrant remember that the
difference between any two consecutive
graphs is only one year one year is
taken out and when you just put into the
data four years are in common the next
year is suddenly these three points come
together again then again we have fish Q
equals two like that then we have fish Q
equals two again we have a few more now
fish Q's again one and we're back in the
second quadrant du equals two and
finally Q equals one
from my personal psychological emotional
point of view these graphs represent the
discovery roughly on par would I had
heard about for example discovery of
radioactivity these graphs are so
unbelievably different from what you
expect that it's a serious task to find
an explanation for them so let me
summarize the properties of the graph q
fish can be equal to 1 or 2 and the
graphs are not stable with respect to
this property it depends on what years
we put together in some particular way
they're not stable and the quadrant
containing the points is also not stable
if the fish prejudice were correct then
a practical statistical investigation of
this would have to have the response
that either Q is always 1 or 2 and if Q
so is 1 it would always be in the same
quadrant the the graphs that we have
seen completely contradict this on the
other hand the line in the graph
containing all three points is
completely stable there is not a single
sample in the 14 windows in which the 3
points are not on the line so the
property the line contains 3 points is
stable the line let's see a line
containing 3 points is definitely stable
but much more is true which is why I
have the transparency the lines coincide
it's always the same line
let's take a look for example at the
last we have a glass window okay last
window and I go back until I have these
coins to end points for example
okay I've coincident points on window
number seven and this is window number
fourteen if I superimpose window windows
7 on 14 which have no points in common
they're disjoint windows it's a little
hard to do this very accurately but you
can see that roughly to the accuracy I
can do that
these coincident points here lie all
together in fact they're on top of 1 in
window 14 so if I lift this up see
there's a point here and on top of that
are the coincident points of Windows 7
ok now that's it that's such an enormous
coincidence that it cannot be a random
effect so lines coincide and these two
things are non random effects because it
is in this style of of sloppy
conventional statistics it has an
unbelievably small probability that for
no reason at all the points these points
coincide you could make one more
demonstration of that for example I take
window five and compare it to say window
one which is a long line one and then
the one the line doesn't go into the
next quadrant but you can still see that
the points in window five which is just
joined from in the one lie and the
continuation of this line almost exactly
okay so these are clearly non random
effects
but in accordance with my discussion
there is also random effect namely the
position position of points on the line
even if line is not drawn in a
particular graph on the line equals
random in my sense it's not constrained
in fact this is exactly what the theorem
here says the theorem claims that under
the conditions stated over there the
points must always lie within a narrow
band of this line the narrower the band
they clear the assumption of law noise
but nothing is said about where they lie
so the actual position is left to be
random because the the the theorem which
gives a precise mathematical statement
says nothing about it a more
mathematical way of saying it is this
suppose a line L is generated by two
points by two points this statement is a
rule which says that I must somehow get
two points which one a fixed line with a
fixed line a fixed L is generated by two
points so the line is fixed but the
statement the two points generate that
line says nothing about where these
points are except that they cannot
effectively coincide because that would
be a violation of statement generated
but this is not an interesting no
difficulty they can be essentially
anywhere on the line as long as they're
not exactly coincident therefore
according to my definition where they
are is random therefore we see that the
standard statistical prejudice
which incidentally gives you one point
and this one point wanders around like
crazy because of this fact one point is
random the standard statistical
prejudice is dead wrong in this case but
the correct explanation of data with Q
equals two is very stable with respect
to all the windows so all the data and
at the same time it explains why nothing
intelligent can be said about nothing
nothing further can be said about where
these points are they happen to be the
effect of this part of the matrix when I
write the expression Sigma hat was Sigma
tilde minus 1 and by explicitly
analyzing the algebra by which this
calculation is made you can easily see
that it is this point of a matrix that
causes these these parts of the matrix
with positive causes these points to
move up and down I just want to make one
comment as to why this is deadly for
classical economics the classical I can
electrics I proceed by making one such
assumption and in this case it doesn't
matter which point I look at every one
of the points is randomly varying over
the over the windows if I make this
assumption then I have the statement
that there is one linear relation
between the variables for example you to
this point here and that it causes a big
trouble to econometricians if this point
wanders over here which we have seen
occurs back and forth throughout this
data because here even a sign of the
coefficients changes into the opposite
which had causes serious problems of
economic interpretation well the reason
why this happens and reason why this
Stannis's go prejudiced with one point
is totally false is that a single point
on a line is never identifiable because
what is identified was the line itself
the line can be generated by two points
but the generators cannot be identified
therefore a single point of
significance so to conclude let me state
one theorem which follows from this set
up by mathematical problems but which
has terrible implications on practice
and which is a reason why classical
economics died once you saw these things
the theorem says if you don't know what
you are doing doing which is technically
the same use the wrong prejudice guess
or prejudice then all your computations
noise no information at all thank you
very much